[Musique]
l'épidémie de surdoses purge de canada a
pris une ampleur catastrophique depuis
le début de la pandémie devait 19 de
2019 à 2020 les dessins ont doublé pour
atteindre plus de 6000 morts par année
ça c'est cette personne qui perdent la
vie chaque jour
si québec a autrefois été relativement
épargnée la province est aujourd'hui
rattrapé par de sinistres statistiques
au début de la pandémie coc1 multiplié
par 7 des semaines avec 702 maintenant
et au delà des chiffres l'épidémie
sourde aux risques dit ma fille elle
pensait vraiment qu'elle était
invincible que ça lui arriverai pas
[Musique]
l'ennemi avait témoin d'un canal
explique
marie-france ismeca clown est décédé
d'une surdose le 19 avril dernier il
n'avait que 23 ans
dépendance aux opiacés elle suivait un
programme de substitution par la
méthadone on appelle encore les
résultats de l'autopsié mais on pense
que ce soit calais l'aisne si je vous
soit qu'elles sont car arrêter battre
parce qu'il y avait trop de
cocaïne c'est la cauquenne dans ce que
la cauquenne qu'elle avait pris avec
l'état donne et puis revint axe un gros
mélange mais en 2020 le québec comptait
550 décès reliés à une intoxication
droit en 2019 on en dénombrait 233 7
années déjà la santé publique s'inquiète
de voir circuler du crack contaminés au
fatah nil ou de la cocaïne coupée au
cathinone
mari francis en était d'ailleurs à sa
deuxième surtout la première fois un ami
lui a sauvé la vie qu'elle en parlait
toujours à l'avs est tellement pas que
ça se reproduise ça c'est reprendre les
quatre ans plus tard au québec le fin
d'année loue ses analogues ont été
détectés dans 24 % des décès reliés à
une intoxication aux drogues en 2021 en
fait depuis deux ans les consommateurs
depuis et non plus vraiment choix de
consommer du fin d'année c'est ce qui se
trouve dans la drogue qui circule sur le
marché noir et c'est ce que s'injecte
alexandra qui est intervenante en
réduction des méfaits à saint-girons et
avait commencé à acheter une bouteille
de vin
la fin du mois sa tête un fédéraux on a
tous des soldats oui j'en ai fait 211
seulement pourquoi les gens font des
surdoses puis pour tous et pourtant le
sexe et de fentanyl on sait qu'il ya des
risques mais c'est ce que j'achète
toujours les renards même personne ce
jour restée fermée très tour mais
j'avais un ami qui peut en avoir fait
que j'allais chez lui puis ces cinq six
sept fontanel choquée j'ai que la moitié
de ce que je fais d'habitude puis du
fait une surdose
en tout elle sera entendue dans le
coquet le supporter n 1 dans le cristal
si elle accepte de consommer devant la
caméra c'est pour déstigmatiser lusage
d'opioïdes
parce qu'elle en a assez de se cacher et
de voir mourir son entourage la crise et
son dos entre autres c'est le ca gosses
difficilement parce que nous n'avons pas
le nommer vont se cacher si on peut le
dire ils révèlent moins de gens qui
concernerait seul est-ce que tu observe
une augmentation des dons emploi avec là
que vides
l'hérault mauvais frontale il est arrivé
à montréal qu'on avait des surdoses
minimum une ou deux par jour en occident
même soir rue une fois oui j'allais
observé j'ai perdu quatre personnes en
une semaine c'est à cette époque là ce
moment là aussi le ca fait pas si
longtemps
fut tellement cruel parce qu'on
s'habitue à l'amant
aujourd'hui et est systématiquement la
drogue est conscient après un an
d'attenté de dispensaires l'organisme
communautaire pour lequel elle travaille
il est d'ailleurs d'obtenir une
exemption au gouvernement fédéral pour
pouvoir manipuler des drogues pour en
faire un mail
comme le fait cactus au centre-ville de
montréal
et puis maintenant huit mois
croyez moi pour sauver des vies grâce à
ça c'est évident on n'est pas dans un
mois de panique mais quand on a fait des
alertes parce que c'était vraiment
dangereux on n'arrive pas à trouver
autre chose avec le spectre mail voir
récemment batch là où le premier match
c'était du fatah n'y est donc quelque
chose de très puissant quoi et ça ça
nous parle d'aviser les gens et ça sauve
des vies directement la kétamine au
benadryl peut-être tamboura pas l'étape
6 cause qui nous dit que tu vas pas
finir mon les rails du métro
passe comme on a des gens qui sont
tombés comme ça devant les rails du
métro tu vois et tout ça c'est des vies
sauvées
[Musique]
si l'analyse de substance et les
services d'injection supervisée sont
d'excellents outils pour combattre la
crise des opioïdes ils ne sont qu'un
pansement sur une hémorragie qui n'est
pas près de s'arrêter selon jean
françois mary s'arrêtera pas est ce que
on a eu un manque cité par rapport à
l'avenir au contraire on voit le
contexte actuel tout pousse à consommer
des opiacés des antidépresseurs et des
anxiolytiques
des stimulants pour avoir du fun et
oublié un peu tout ça donc c'est sûr
qu'on peut sauver des vies mais on est
en train de vider un océan avec une
excuse
[Musique]
au québec certains médecins prescrivent
de l'hydromorphone à leurs patients aux
prises avec des dépendances
depuis 2001 le gouvernement fédéral à
accorder du financement à une vingtaine
de projets pilotes qui offre un
approvisionnement sécuritaire andreu des
initiatives semblables ont fait leurs
preuves ailleurs dans le monde notamment
en suisse mais jean françois mary va
plus loin et demande la fin de la
prohibition de ces substances y ont en
réalité à coûte pas cher et ça on le
choisit c'est un choix de société les
gens pensent que les gens veulent des
drogues gratuite non les gens veulent
des drogues de qualité à un prix non
prohibitionniste combien de maires ont
perdu leurs enfants à cause qu'elle
consommer des substances même 16 été
capable de s'en occuper
des maires comme geneviève vézina
lévesque qui tente de faire le deuil de
sa fille deux semaines après son départ
par trois fois mari francis a tenté de
se défaire de sa dépendance en
participant dès thérapies sans succès on
a tout fait on l'a aidé on a tout fait
ce qu'on a pu s'emparer mois et il faut
que les gens comprennent que
c'est une vraie maladie comme le cancer
puis elle voulait s'en sortir
[Musique]
et c'est une bataille à chaque jour
contre la dépendance donc je me sens en
paix de savoir que finalement
el malick en paix et libre
dépendance mais
or comme je t'aime c'est très récent
donc
je pense que je réalise pas non plus pas
100% coeur
c'est parfait
m
mais
allez
[Musique]